this week is national robotics week
it is it's national robotics week it's a
whole week dedicated to robotics to
inspire
students in engineering related fields
now why do i know this well because my
son
is into robotics that's right he's
really into robotics loves building
uh robots and drones and he's very
passionate about it and
anyway i think i think robots are pretty
cool so i just wanted to take
a moment to thank the robots
who work on our show wait a minute
conan there's no robots working on this
show
uh yeah of course andy uh there aren't
okay anyway tonight on the show we have
an incredible guest
wait wait conan why did you say there
are robots working on the show
you're kidding right no after all these
years
you still haven't figured it out man
so much for artificial intelligence andy
wait conan are you saying that's right
andy
you are the robot
no it can't be what about all my
memories
for god's sake andy we implanted those
haven't you ever wondered why all your
memories are all just stock footage
no my college graduation
[Music]
learning to ride a bike
my first kiss
[Music]
the birth of my children
[Music]
yes all royalty-free very cheap stock
footage
sourced from the internet oh it can't be
true
but it is andy ask yourself what human
being would choose
freely to hang out with me for almost 30
years
okay yeah i must be a robot yeah
definitely a robot
yeah hey uh andy uh resume sidekick mode
okay
you said it going you're the king